Hey Dr Peterson,
I'm curious about the connection between
aesthetic beauty and religious
experience.
I think you've hinted at it once or
twice over the course of the lecture.
Um,
is it possible,
um,
for something that's incredibly
beautiful to evoke or religion,
religious or mystical experience or
something of in the same ballpark is
that's what they're for?
Yeah.
No,
I mean if you look at the structure of
like a,
like a renaissance cathedral was just
going to check my,
uh,
my tag onto.
I apologize you mentioned trump.
My tag onto that question.
The next part was um,
um,
is that why we have cathedral is built
like a spectacular buildings as opposed
to make socks or something?
Right?
Well,
it's,
if you're going to how's the ultimate
ideal,
you build something beautiful right to,
to represent it's dwelling place and it
should be beautiful and this is
something that people do not take
seriously.
And this is especially something we
don't take seriously in Canada.
I mean,
one of the you think about,
you think about all the hundreds of
millions of dollars that were invested
into beauty in Europe,
mean spectacular,
excessive investment in beauty that's
paid back.
God only knows how many multiples of
times people make pilgrimages to Europe
constantly because it's so beautiful
that it just staggers you.
Beauty is so valuable and we're so
afraid of it and I think we're afraid of
it because it does.
It's a pathway.
It's not the only pathway to the divine.
I mean there's lot.
There's pathways to the divine.
Love is one of them I suppose,
but beauty especially for people who
have an affinity for,
but it's.
It's like music.
It's one of those things that you can't
argue against,
right?
You can't even understand.
It just hits you and it does.
It shows you.
Well,
it shows you the ideal.
That's one way of thinking about it,
but it also shows you.
I think it's like a vision of the
potential future.
It's something like that as well that if
we just got our act together and
beautified things that that's the place
that we can inhabit and not winning
noble us and that's why this Jerusalem,
the heavily city is paved with
gemstones,
you know,
their crystalline,
the admit light and yeah,
it's the proper dwelling place for an
enlightened consciousness.
Ut is the proper dwelling place for an
enlightened consciousness and we,
we ignore it at our inner spiritual and
economic peril.
It's our,
like,
it's obvious that,
but there's almost nothing more valuable
than but economically,
practically.
So yeah.
Why that is.
I mean,
I don't.
It's very.
Who knows.
I mean why we,
we experienced gemstones for example,
is beautiful.
It's very mysterious,
but they're deep reasons for it.
So.
Yep.